yeah that's what you make gloves out of
[Music]
oh my god guys I really want to show you
how to make this Indian giant it's so
good okay but first a little bit of
backstory as you guys know I post a lot
of photos on Instagram
naturally I follow a lot of Instagram
photographers one of which is pork box
pork box is awesome they do a lot of
interviews with cinematographers and
they post different photographers from
around Instagram it's a portfolio of the
best photography work on Instagram let's
follow them going through other stuff
commenting and the guy responded his
name is Madi find out he's from India
and he's coming to visit LA and while he
was here he taught me how to make this
authentic Indian chai and ever since
I've been addicted I've been obsessed
I got friggin all the spices I got the
mortar and pestle having a chai every
night it just calms me down it's so
peaceful the first thing you got to do
when we're talking fresh chai is get
fresh ingredients which is why we're at
namaste spice land in pasadena ratios
pots and pans whatever forget all that
stuff we're here for the highest quality
spices that's the first thing first and
foremost
and they honestly Nick I do feel some
pressure right now I am a young padawan
of chai I just want to share my love
tribe with you guys I hope I do Maddie
in the whole country of India so Matt
you told me about this place let's go
check it out black tea specifically red
label this is the stuff that Maddie was
like yo there's the one you want her
here we got cloves fennel seeds these
are the ones you'll need black pepper
it's very important seven sticks whole
cinnamon sticks the ginger root fresh
first I'm gonna get it and create some
of this down and throw that into the mix
cardamom this kind of makes up the main
flavor of the chai this is per cup of
chai you can multiply the amounts
depending on how many cups you're doing
so we'll start with cloves so that's
about as much clothes
as you'll need tennessee's you want like
a whole pinch of this stuff like that
much next is black pepper maybe three I
don't know you might need more you'll
see six you're gonna need just the chunk
just one little chunk plenty and then
fun light-hearted memory there's are
these little seeds in here you want
about 14 of these little seeds this is
the flavor of the shine right here I'm
gonna take all this grind it up in here
[Music]
so basically for one cup of chai you
want half whole milk and half water I'll
bring that to a boil all right so guys
play ingredients are prepped my milks
boiling almost the next step is to hope
that I got these ratios correct
especially since I'm doing it in bulk
it's time we're just dropping this spice
straight in guys
succeeding AJ here you go Norman I'm
going to Mexico
what yeah my Wendy's family has a house
down there we went down there and I
signed into my netflix account dude all
different stuff all way better stuff
than what we get up here so I'm going
dude I'm just gonna be there for like a
week I'll be literally to watch Netflix
yeah I'm just gonna be p.m. you can
basically set it up as a proxy tell it
you're in Mexico and it will let you
watch any of the content they're from
what do you mean talat I'm in Mexico do
some research on VPN
[Music]
I figured out why today's episode is
brought to you by expressvpn that's
right I'd like to thank them for being
here because without them I would have
never researched VPNs and I would have
never figured out that VPNs they're kind
of like secure links between two parts
of the Internet and a VPN service does a
couple of things for you number one it
can make your connection more secure by
encrypting your information as it goes
between different links of the Internet
in addition VPN services allow you to
proxy your server meaning that you can
pick a server from another region or
another country even and tell the rest
of the Internet that that's where you
are basically giving you anonymity and
unlocking access to content that's only
available in that region hence why we're
here right now simply by using
expressvpn I'll be able to sign into my
Netflix account and tell the Internet
that I'm actually down there when I'm
actually up here isn't that great I've
tried other VPN services in the past
myself expressvpn is definitely one of
the fat system one of the best so if you
guys go and sign up now with expressvpn
dot-com slash corridor crew and you buy
a one-year package you'll get three
months free if you don't want to make
that kind of commitment it's just seven
bucks a month with a 30-day money-back
guarantee they also have it on phones
and on tablets so they're mobile you can
go anywhere it's an app to just go to
expressvpn comm slash corridor crew
that's expr ESS VPN calm slash corridor
crew and you too can be an anonymous
secure internet rogue
okay fresh ginger fresh ginger so I just
let this sit it's all you do let it sit
yes now this is very important because
it's happening a couple times it like
boiled over and I lost a lot of the
spice and a lot of the milk we were
watching the first video this topic
Manny what he do wrong
he just didn't take it away I dad it
picked up me there's no I
it gets he feeling he'd years away yeah
bad that I don't but if you don't watch
it with an eagle eye it's gonna boil
over you got to be ready when milk boils
and turns into this foam in it this was
completed nobody's coming up
[Music]
and removed from the heat
yeah so it almost came up I removed from
the heat getting a little stir
see how it's turning orange it's good go
back on you won't let it bubble up three
times three times it's gonna boil up so
the third time yeah number three
[Music]
I'm gonna go one more for good luck
that's basically it
now we gotta pour this out you got your
sifter this is always a process here
because I always spill this thing get
yourself a pot with a lip on it also get
yourself a chai pot because if you're
cooking like meats and other things in
here your ties and sour tasting like
meat and that's gross you're probably
gonna see me mess this up so graceful
bad trip
good match yeah it's a good batch just a
spice patch dude dude dad is good myself
Clint Niko we've been into dark souls
remastered on switch it's great we've
been playing the crap out of it for the
last two weeks and we are trying to
figure out if we can make a video around
this basically a collection of our
favorite moments our jokes from the game
and doing it live action we're gonna
brainstorm a little bit and see what we
can come up with I want to know what are
we trying to accomplish that way we can
start interrupting that with all these
gags yeah we're trying to get ready for
a boss fight but that means now everyone
has their own reasons
oh if people keep losing connection and
it's like god it's like I had both you
guys ready and then now like one of them
or even just like super funny like
you're have a person they do that they
don't like a stranger or something he'd
summon somebody and they'd show up and
just jump off the ledge and die and he's
like people are getting ready for boss
fight it's like starts at 4:00 summoning
his friends things that are happening
during this we're not sure the order but
it's your chunky rose trying to like
trying to lighten that your load to like
get ready to fight we have like one
person who's really eager to see the
boss so he's like says he's just gonna
poke his head in and he poke at it and
then he gets sucked in and here died and
he shows up the person who just can't
stop smashing the pots rolling in the
pots where we would probably just get
some real pots awkward somersaults into
real pots breaking them Sam I'm gonna
just do a draft real quick and see if I
come up with anything
[Music]
what is that it's a choice simulation
great so enjoy our books up doing here
good things happen when cultures come
together guys Cheers it's like Christmas
it's the perfect ball - yeah that's what
you make gloves out of you can make
Gekko skin you can make a loincloth out
of that wait what is its milk milk skin
looks like a giraffe it does fish keep
this what are you gonna do Jake eat this
octopus is that smells kind of good you
might have to drop baby's milk skins
right off the top what is that it looks
like plastic that's kind of cool
can I try it okay
does it does it check in first first
impressions
it smells really good Oh they say that
smell is the 90% it tastes actually
hearing is 84% of smelling good fish
lips I feel calmer on the pond drinking
it I'm getting that tea calming effect
yeah this would be delicious around
around the heart during Thanksgiving and
Christmas
Bailey's to this maybe let me make it
Irish Indian is really good I want to
hide okay here you can chomp the hide
dude Oh what do you see that oh dude
you're freaking shot molten freaking
snake swing pattern that's good it's
smooth nice and smooth nice and creamy
and smooth that's good - Clint thank you
for showing us this and thanks to Maddy
for showing you yes
yeah thank you Maddy and thank you
that's it